chapter three
of um of our book a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century uh so chapter
one
was a sort of theoretical introduction
called the human niche chapter two
uh comprised a deep history of of the
human lineage and then in chapter three
we really get into the meat of the book
chapters three through thirteen
take a system in turn and chapters three
and four are both kind of about um the
body and
and medicine um so you know rather
apropos for what we are talking about
here
i'm going to read just the very
beginning of the chapter
and and then a couple of paragraphs that
are relevant to it
a couple of pages later there's two two
and a half pages here
this is called ancient the chapters
called ancient bodies modern world
we've got a raptor out there calling you
hear that okay
uh the sun the sand bushmen of southern
africa most of whom were
hunter-gatherers until just a few
decades ago
have little trouble with the kinds of
optical illusions that westerners
struggle with
consider two identical lines except that
they have arrowheads at both ends going
in opposite directions
this incidentally is called the muller
lyre illusion and i can for those of you
at home there's a thing there
but you can look that up consider two
identical lines except that they have
arrowheads at both ends going in
opposite directions
they appear to us to be different
lengths even though they are not our
eyes fool us with help from our brains
when asked to do a simple task assess
which line is longer we tend to fail
the sun do not were you to raise an
american infant among the sun though
that baby once it grew up would not have
the same problem that her parents did
with the optical illusion
similarly a son child in manhattan and
susceptibility to the illusion would
again show itself
in this case sensory capability and
physiology are being driven by
differences in experience and
environment
not by genetic differences most readers
of this
of this book likely live in weird
countries western
educated with uh western nations with a
highly educated populous and
industrialized economic base that are
relatively rich and democratic
as societies we have benefited from
industrialization and democracy which
have raised the quality of life for
nearly everyone who lives in these
countries but there are many negative
unintended consequences downstream of
society-wide changes
while it is clear to most people how
much the 21st century weird environment
has expanded the menu of possible
experiences that we have at our backing
call
it is less obvious how 21st century
weird life has curtailed other
experiences often to our detriment
what why can we unlike the sun be fooled
by a simple set of lines
it has to do with an alteration in our
visual sphere our homes are clean
climate-controlled and square just as
depriving kittens of some visual inputs
renders them less capable of seeing as
adults
perhaps with our modern comforts and
conveniences we are effectively
depriving our weird selves and rendering
ourselves less capable
or perhaps our visual capacity is being
tailored to our uniquely square
environment either way modernity is
doing something to us at a deeply
fundamental level
and the fact that we don't understand it
is alarming
one thing we can be sure of is this
models of human behavior and psychology
which tend to be based on empirical
studies of weird undergraduate students
may well be accurate readings of the
psychology and behavior of weird
undergrads
but they do not inherently make for good
models for the rest of the world
indeed it is now clear that we and the
weird countries are outliers when it
comes to many aspects of the human
experience
the implications of this are far more
important than being easily tricked by
visual illusions but understanding why
we are susceptible to such illusions can
provide insight
into the risks of hyper novelty it is
likely that our highly geometric homes
and playgrounds
which make up so much of what we see
during early childhood calibrate our
eyes such that we suffer from such
illusions far more than do those in the
rest of the world
that geometry which we mostly take for
granted emerged in part from being able
to run wood through sawmills and create
dimensional lumber
most people when their culture began to
run wood through sawmills and build
homes at the dimensional lumber that
results
would not have thought to ask what and
our human experience and capability
might be affected by this
dimensional lumber and the carpentered
corners that result are novel features
of the modern humans environment how has
it changed how we perceive the world
reframing your approach to the world
such that those questions do occur to
you
even if you are not sure what the
answers might be is part of the goal of
this book
and then just skipping together skipping
forward a couple of pages
if homes full of carpeted corners have
made us more susceptible to particular
kinds of optical illusions altering our
ability to see
what other costs to a weird lifestyle
might exist
as recently as the 1990s he would have
been considered a crackpot if you had
suggested that spending your work days
sitting at a desk might have long-term
effects on cardiovascular health
or risk of type 2 diabetes no longer
carpentered corners create greater
susceptibility to certain optical
illusions
over-reliance on chairs creates all
manner of negative health outcomes
what then might deodorants and perfumes
have done to our ability to smell the
signals emitted by our bodies
what might lives filled with clocks have
done to our sense of time
what have airplanes done to our sense of
space or the internet to our sense of
competence
what if maps done to our sense of
direction or schools to our sense of
family
so that is all in keeping with the rest
of the conversation that we've been
having
absolutely i mean it goes right to the
issue of heuristics which are built
around the realities
which you have in your developmental
environment and uh
you know the sun live in a very
different developmental environment it's
a it's a
it's a trick that once you see that
you're using these heuristics to great
effect but that they are actually
contingent on being used in
environments in which the conclusions
that they lead you to tend to be right
and not wrong
a whole world opens up yeah and this is
not this is certainly not a noble savage
mistake that we're making nor a looking
at the past through rose-colored glasses
uh it is it is certainly true and as we
say elsewhere i think in this chapter
even
excuse me that antibiotics vaccines and
surgery are three of the most remarkable
feats of western medicine and the world
is much better for all of them that is
true
and the fact that they are all of them
all of them over
applied and used in places where they
actually do harm
is also true and this again is not a
always where your seat belt in the car
stop asking questions sort of a thing
this is actually observing that
saying that something is a major advance
and also questioning whether or not it
should be ubiquitously applied
blanket-like over every possible thing
that happens
though you can have those two thoughts
i think that's amazing and i don't think
it goes here
in the same head at the same time in
fact we need to we
need to be having this conversation yeah
and in fact even in the case of
something like
you just put on your seatbelt and don't
think because it's much more likely to
save your life than cost it
you might also think well what if i did
get involved in the nuance discussion
and i realized
that rather than just bank on the ratio
of these things
i would like to have a device that
allows me to cut a seat belt
quickly if i cannot escape it in the car
with you so
you get the benefit of the clicking the
seat belt automatically
while retaining the ability to escape it
if you cannot undo it
um in a kind of accident that's unusual
and there are many of these things you
know just because you think vaccines are
the way doesn't mean you should be
scoffing at ivermectin that to me looks
like
a business conclusion not a medical
conclusion a medical conclusion
would have people who are enthusiastic
about vaccines also enthusiastic about
avermectin
um so in any case uh
it's the discussion stupid right we have
to have the discussion that's the point
and you know does that mean that
discussion is safe and won't cost lives
no but it's a net question right and you
know it isn't simply about lives either
there is there is a real question i
would argue
and i have not yet heard pushback on
this i would argue
it does not make sense to sacrifice the
lives of healthy young people in order
to save
older unhealthy people it just doesn't
it's not something a rational society
does you protect
children and so that means that the
calculation is not a simple one
under under any circumstances that's
right but we can do better
we can do better by discussing things
yeah we can